D3 isn't necessarily magic, but it hides a lot of complexity for you.
So it might seem mysterious.
But if you dig deep enough,
you can always find out where the source of what it's doing is.
In this case, the data attribute in the DOM.
And something I don't advise, but you can do, is you actually mutate the data of
this circle by changing individual fields on the .__data__attribute.
And again, this is a somewhat bad practice unless you
know exactly what you're doing since it could lead to issues of data corruption,
here we've simply changed the attendance of the first gain to 1 million.
But enough fooling around.
Let's get back to the code and actually draw some circles.